e vamos falar de uma coisa que anda
trabalhará há mais de 20 anos que são as
microalgas
imagino que muitos de vocês é um tema
que não conhecem outros certamente já se
cruzaram com as microalgas e eu tenho
alguns objetivos para a conversa
partilha que vou ter com os cursos
uma delas é que vocês fiquem a conhecer
um caminho deste fantástico mundo verde
que eu vou partilhar convosco também não
é propriamente os desafios
as microalgas são seres microscópicos
que existem na superfície terrestre
as mulheres são mais uns milhares de
espécies poucas tão conhecidas na
alimentação porque estão estudadas em
muito poucas são usadas na alimentação
humana
a autoridade europeia para a segurança
alimentar neste momento só tem aprovadas
três espécies para consumo humano
aquarela vulgares aspirina ea patrícia
michui mas não se assustem que não vou
falar não me fez nada disso eu vim aqui
partilhar a minha experiência é a roda
destes seres fantásticos e falarmos um
bocadinho é de como é que nós podemos
desenvolver nos numa causa e pensar como
é que todos podemos contribuir para
mudar alguma coisa daquilo que a nossa
alimentação
agora vai eu podia começar a falar um
carinho sobre a sustentabilidade
ficava banho mas não vou fazer nós
estamos em plena campanha eleitoral e
este é o tema com a todos os políticos
em campanha e portanto não vou debater
aqui questões de sustentabilidade parte
do princípio que todos tivemos o que é
eo que importa portanto não vou falar em
sustentabilidade vou falar algumas
coisas que nos preocupam vou falar do da
alimentação portanto vamos entrar na
alimentação
nós estamos a caminhar e não voltou a
apresentar as teorias sobre enfim o
drama que vamos todos viver daqui a 30
anos é resultado das alterações
climáticas e do centro já todos ouvimos
falar disse
há teorias mais catastróficos outros
menos até aqui nem acredito nas
alterações climáticas é uma verdade
mas há uma coisa que é certa o nosso
planeta usar os recursos vão levar à
escassez hídrica é que esses da
universidade esquecesse terra arável faz
nos pensar o que é que nós vamos fazer
aqui um fator que nós não conseguimos
controlar que o crescimento demográfico
e sem assento água e os estudos sejam
eles quais forem há muitos cenários
apontam que 30 anos nós vamos ter mais
nove mil milhões de pessoas para comer
no nosso planeta
nós hoje somos um pouco mais 7 mil
milhões então é muito boa pra comer e se
o circo os recursos são cada vez mais
escassos nós temos que pensar em
alternativas podemos não fazer nada e
depois logo se vê é uma opção já fizemos
isso ao longo dos anos várias coisas mas
penso que as pessoas que pensam sobre
estas coisas querem fazer alguma coisa
eu acredito nos jovens
eu acredito na nossa capacidade de
mudança e é por isso que vai partilhar
convosco uma alternativa à imensa
aquelas que venham logo a vossa cabeça
sal
o cae indústria alimentar e mensch
província para que nós disponibilizamos
mais de 30 por cento daquilo que
produzimos num cenário onde a produção
agrícola não vai acompanhar as
necessidades que nós vamos ter em termos
de comida e expressa uma nota 10 pra
pensar mais 30 por cento daquilo que os
produtos importante é a atenção ao
desperdício já todos ouvimos isso não
vou abordar esse tema
depois podemos pensar em alterar os
nossos hábitos alimentares aqui vos
desafiar outros através das microalgas
que já vão falar mas há mais coisas a
fazer não é só com microalgas
vocês têm que mudar o conceito de
alimentação nós temos não só voz isso
somos nós é que nós aprendemos todos os
livros que é importante ter uma
alimentação saudável
hoje temos que juntar aqui mais uma
palavra soldável e sustentável ou seja
temos que nos preocupar conosco e com o
que os peões ganho e com um ambiente e
eu não vou entrar aqui na polêmica da
carne de vaca estes últimos dias têm
sido muito animados sobre esse polêmica
muitas opiniões é outra coisa que eu não
vou falar que tá não falou nada já foram
tantas que não vou falar depois também
há outras estratégias comemos
é produto de proximidade a produção
local é importante nós investirmos os
produtos não andar a passear a correr um
planeta
andaram estudos é é ter força enorme
esplanada mas eu tenho que ser a nossa
dieta vai outra vez que a história do
abacate que vem lá de trás dos autores
de outro continente e que tem uma pegada
ecológica e normas porque sabemos que os
fãs bem vai ter mercado como isso outros
outros alimentos não vou falar disso
final o que eu vou falar
então eu vou te falar uma coisa que são
recursos que nós temos no planeta e que
são pouco explorados e que estão
subexploradas e que nós podemos tirar
porque deus porque sim tá muito nas
nossas mãos está na consciência e na
capacidade de cada um conseguir fazer
lugar
ok então a mão de recursos há muitos
recursos todos nós sabemos que hoje em
dia é nós deixarmos de comer algumas
coisas comigo na antiguidade que comiam
até no tempo dos nossos avós em outro
veículo uma sopa de beldroegas
fantástica já ninguém combinou drogas é
m nosso pensamento é que aí nessas
coisas que nós deixamos de comer ao
longo do tempo e depois mais tarde vamos
buscar também porque as microalgas que
que isto com este aspeto fantástico ver
curioso são micro organismos que fazem
fotossíntese são fotossintéticos e tem a
capacidade de captar o dióxido de
carbono que é produzido girar para o dia
o seu alimento produzir a matéria
orgânica e libertar oxigênio na
atmosfera são nossos aliados na
mitigação do senhor hoje só que eu não
sei se você achava que mais 50% do
oxigênio atmosférico do nosso planeta é
produzido por micro ondas
isso é uma responsabilidade enorme um
cheiro de um pm e só por isso já chegava
a conversa vamos comer porque elas são
boas tal não chega às drogas tem uma
particularidade acumulou quantidades
elevadíssimas de proteína
é nós temos algumas espécies que podem
acumular cerca de 70% proteína e brutal
acolá associada à promoção de proteína
produzida em outros ingredientes
bioativos eu prometi que não ia usar
palavrões mas bioativos é normal
são ingredientes que o efeito benéfico
no nosso organismo como os ácidos gordos
polinsaturados como antioxidantes com
substâncias anti-inflamatórias portanto
o consumo de microalgas tem também esta
particularidade de ter um conjunto com o
porte que tenha um benefício direto na
nossa seu uso certo portanto já estão já
estão aqui é perceber que temos aqui um
elemento chave dos povos lar é ter uma
alimentação saudável e sustentável
este novo que engraçado nunca tinha
pensado nisso nada novo stent que sim há
milhares de anos consome microalgas
nutro em várias zonas do planeta
os povos orientais trair as microalgas
como elemento essencial da sua dieta e
há muitas histórias sobre o consumo de
microalgas ao longo do tempo é não sei
se vocês sabem mas quando os estados
unidos fizeram um embargo o japão na
segunda guerra mundial os japoneses que
comem tudo tudo tudo podem por razões
óbvias da sua estrutura da sua geografia
salvaram o japão da fama pelo consumo de
microalgas dedicaram a produção de
microalgas
já o consumo das mesmas ea vários
escritos sobre isso em que o japão
conseguiu sobreviver o embargo graças ao
consumo das drogas
nós conhecemos nos às vezes destas
missões que a história nos dá e também
sempre tentaram inventar a roda quando a
roda já foi inventada há muitos anos e
vai hoje em dia algumas proposições em
áfrica por exemplo chave é uma coisa
muito engraçada que as populações locais
de câncer
a produção espirulina apocalípticas pelo
mineiro microalgas podem estar aqui
biólogos não haja confusão se iluminam
assim a nova bactéria que agora sinto-me
e teve uma
traçando uma cultura e tem um nome
bonito usar transpira as potências não é
uma micro onda mas funciona com uma
micro ondas por ter um processo de
crescimento evidente que grosso modo
toda a gente chama de microalgas
tentasse pelo mina comprovou vai
continuar aqui no nosso contest sm causa
então e eu contar diz que machado essas
populações locais fazem é o cultivo é
opcional da aspirina fazem skagen ao sol
e produzem um produto tradicional que
chama de e e que está a ser um momento
fundamental para ultrapassar as
diferenças nutricionais daquelas
populações
a fao é presidente disto tavares
incentivos fortíssimos para que isso
aconteça porque há crianças com problema
de nutrição grave
o mesmo acontece na índia com programas
específicos para o desenvolvimento de
calçados que são dados nas escolas
também pra casa com aspirina não é pra
casa porque o mal da micro-alga é muito
fácil xira em ambientes apple controlado
portanto já sabem o caminho que são as
microalgas uma diversidade enorme nós
temos ficado em 3 precisar de algumas
restrições da união europeia que mora o
perigo é perceberem os resultados dos
nossos ensaios científicos e esses
processos são complexos e já perceberam
a riqueza que está na nossa frente e
avançar
eu consegui descansar trabalhar e está
há 20 anos na altura nós usávamos
produções feitas aqui nos laboratórios
do nega e do imã muito nestes últimos
anos nós tivemos um boom menor no
crescimento micro ondas ea empresas
chile já disse mas na produção de
microalgas para consumo alimentar as
grandes empresas começaram por fazer
suas produções publicar a produção de
violência há 15 anos pra cá as grandes
conclusões é que fatos pode ser uma
fonte alimentar importantes e os
produções premiou israel ficaram enfim
adaptadas a maior parte da produção para
consumo humano e voz de ana c laudos não
nós portugal nessa somos dos países da
europa que está em melhores condições
para a produção de microalgas temos
quatro grandes empresas guarda
estão a produzir petróleo estão a
produzir microondas com uma qualidade
extraordinária acrescenta tudo o que são
os requisitos dos ingredientes
alimentares como como outro ingrediente
alimentar qualquer é o shampoo e chivas
r atual titular tanto podem ser obtidas
no laboratório conheço o trecho em casa
e usam diretamente nas suas preparações
fresca que é fantástico avais várias
várias escalas de produção a cair nesse
reator horizontais ou verticais a áreas
de implementação enorme abril que
utilizava e toda ela reciclada e
portanto nós conseguimos extrair é
biomassa
não sei acho que ainda não estão
convencidos
nós é que no isa temos uma grande equipa
que trabalha há mais de 20 anos neste
assunto temos que produzir muito
trabalho e só agora
passado este tempo todo e precisamos
avançar é ser solicitados pelas
indústrias com um interesse enorme neste
tipo de de ingredientes e porque 20 anos
é muito tempo a indústria perceber
porque eu acho que nem sempre as
estratégias que nós usamos são as mais
adequadas nossos investigadores temos
muitas vezes preocupados com a seguir o
que elas fazem o que elas têm quais são
os benefícios mas isso tem que passar
por o consumidor tem que passar para
vocês eu vou te contar uma experiência
muito rapidamente uma experiência que
twitter há dois anos e que vai se
prolongar por mais alguns anos num
projecto que chama ao dito filter que é
um projeto que envolve 27 parceiros
internacionais é japão bélgica holanda
enfim - não vou dizer todo empresas
universidades e não só em que é lembrado
pela noruega noruega editar a acreditar
no imenso
nesta conversa que hoje estou aqui
trazer ou seja que é possível tornar
isto realmente uma fonte alimentar
sustentável e que faça parte dos nossos
dias
e qual é a diferença de trabalhar aqui e
é isso que eu escrevo esta é a principal
mensagem é um trabalho interdisciplinar
é preciso ver que todas as áreas são
convocadas para este problema que não é
não são engenheiros alimentar não só
nutricionistas não são bioquímicos não
são um engenheiro ciganos que tem uma
mil própria uma nova cultura e vocês
alguns engenheiros agrônomos tem também
perceber isso
mas somos todos envolvidos neste
problema o facebook hoje nem lembro o
nome
faz hoje um ano eu estava na
universidade que o é fazer o maior
quando os seus mais engraçados da minha
vida ser uma simples exame de que vá dar
um seminário de duas horas na
universidade que o que eu ia perder
hamburgo 80 alunos internacionais sobre
o que são as microondas em potência
vamos lá estou aqui partilhar convosco
mas depois terão são alunos ciências da
comunicação e pânico como é que eu vou
explicar isto
e fui assim contou explicar a vocês que
foi absolutamente fantástico os volantes
tiveram que fazer um trabalho seu depois
acompanhei sobre estratégias de
comunicar esta questão e nessa altura
percebi que é está a mudança
a mudança está nas pessoas a mudança
está em saber comunicar esses alunos
fizeram trabalhos absolutamente
incríveis e eu tenho certeza qualquer um
de vocês se vista que os trabalhos de
comunicação e acreditar fortemente no
potencial que este microrganismo está em
provar a nossa alimentação porque é
preciso saber comunicar nós temos na
sociedade da comunicação e então mais
uma vez a interdisciplinaridade votarmos
todos complicados com o assunto e não
trato e ciências de comunicação que seis
microalgas não é isso que o truque para
nós conseguirmos chegar a um bom
resultado quem ficava e que realmente é
transformador
todos temos coisas que conseguimos foi
em conjunto vamos lavar e usar é preciso
ter coragem e coragem de partilhar é
isto é a primeira produção que nós
tivemos na noruega e
não é portanto que nós temos aqui sempre
este bonequinhos assim tipo banda
desenhada não é porque fica bonito é
porque este projeto envolve um conjunto
de pessoas que estão ligadas às crianças
e acreditamos que as crianças podem
crescer é comer microalgas este projeto
começa por explicar fortemente as
crianças nas escolas o que são as drogas
se vocês entrarem netra venham se um não
tem grassado banda desenhada das
microalgas todas e tal porque
acreditamos na conexão e conexão tem que
começar cedo e esse um dos grandes
objetivos
o que nós temos feito aqui no isa nestes
20 anos muito trabalho
alguns já cansaram e obviamente que nós
temos tido a nível europeu eu acho com
alguma modéstia e até a nível mundial
marcado posição nem por pressão de
biomassa microalga lá em várias matrizes
alimentar e temos muitos trabalhos
publicados
não vai falar isso aqui mais uma coisa
que eu não vou falar e eu queria
partilhar convosco duas abordagens
diferentes que tenham seguido e última
mais recente que tem dado resultados
completamente diferente bom
a primeira abordagem diria que é muito
científica muito chata naquilo que são
os centros tradicionais de investigação
estes produtos vão desde as maioneses
para santos províncias bolachas massas
alimentícias o pão-nosso vamos um
impacto vem por pressão das microalgas
do ponto de vista teológico do ponto de
vista tecnológico porque nós estamos a
falar de um ingrediente que está em
proteína tem ácidos gordos etc
do ponto de vista da concessão do
movimento o movimento tem que ser 'vinha
vão poder ter essa impressão se vocês
quiserem lá em casa fizeram a
experiência de fazer uma massa de pão
executar uma colher microalgas podem
comer mas tem alguma produza não correr
bem
nós temos que desempenhar tudo movimento
rock e assim torna se também outra coisa
que podemos colher não ia aguentar
alguns médicos recomendam mas depois
você fica com uma péssima impressão das
microalgas então a instalar na gem que
uma abordagem formal
a barragem que nós temos seguir nos
últimos anos que uma abordagem que vai
mais próximo do consumidor e não posso
alongar mas alguém tem idéia de quem tem
é que o autor do desenvolvimento desde o
show completo espirulina quer que a
fruta está comprometida e sim com esta
causa e tá desenvolver alimentos
produtos com esta lógica que estou a
falar tanto este cachorro com pontos
pelo mina é um cachorro com pretendem
certo e desenvolvido pelo iqa finalmente
as empresas acordaram vamos nós a curva
também nós temos aqui temos uma ligação
muito forte entre engenharia alimentar e
ciências gastronômicas e os nossos
alunos e os nossos colaboradores têm
sido chamados a este propósito e isso
tem um menu que foi desenvolvido aqui
todo estava internacionalmente com flor
ela vulgares e que foi desenvolvido na
área de ciências gastronômicas e isto
não foi o resumo da minha última aula de
rio dia e textura dos alimentos no
mestrado em ciências gastronômicas deste
ano onde o tema foi processado por ela
vulgares em novas procurações alimentar
com todos os alunos e são luís com
experiências muito diferentes temos
jornalistas licenciados em direito enfim
todos são chamados fizeram estas
criações que partilho convosco está tudo
feito fome agora o objetivo é dizer que
no coffee break
vocês vão ter todas as oportunidades de
provar algumas criações que foram feitas
por uma das nossas alunas de ciências
gastronômicas e então poderem dizer que
aceitou este desafio e civil só
estragarem se contarmos com todos não
implementam design obrigado
[Aplausos]